Wow I'm gonna style shit critic guy
remember it so you don't have to hey
what's with the princess hate yes most
little girls fantasize about being a
princess at some point with their
elegant beauty kind heart and enchanted
surroundings the princess for many is
the epitome of femininity buff has been
a bit of a backlash in the past several
years saying that the princess
stereotype is a more damaging fantasy
than an encouraging one even I've had my
rants on the overuse of it and media
you're not really a princess you just
took the title because it's act cute so
is it just innocent make-believe or is
there really something to get angry
about well in order to answer this we
should probably look at what the
majority people take the most offense at
and I guess it's only the most logical
you'll be a cliche to look at the most
famous lineup of princesses Disney
Disney has practically reinvented the
fairy tale and seeing how their princess
line is the best-selling licensed
entertainment character merchandise it's
safe to say they have a clear
understanding of what makes princesses
so popular what do they have in common
well they're all pretty they're all kind
they all have various clothes and
accessories you can buy for them but
naturally the intrigue in owning one has
to come from their personalities formed
in the movies which many consider from
an ethical point of view not the best
role models they don't do anything many
complain they're just damsels waiting to
be rescued and never take responsibility
and getting things done for themselves
instead relying on their status and/or
beauty to get them what they want which
in most cases is just a man and
sometimes that's true Sleeping Beauty
for example I still stand by is one of
the most forgettable characters in
Disney history yeah we all know the
iconic image but her fantasy extends to
her doing absolutely nothing while her
true love comes to save the day and what
of course happens she does absolutely
nothing while her true love comes to
save the day
and on top of that she has nothing else
to make her stand out be unique or have
any specific characteristics so yeah the
argument is pretty valid there the
fucking I'm gonna defend the other
ladies a little bit not that they're
always the best but they're still good
virtues that can be learned from them
Snow White's kindness and helpful nature
for example serves as a second mother
for the doors and anyone that says being
a mother doesn't make a hard-working
responsible woman clearly has never been
one it's work and worse about is that
you don't even get paid for it so the
fact that she can still be pleasant
while also teaching the doors
responsibility may not be major but it's
still something but many would argue
it's one thing for one of them to fall
into that category
what about three we mentioned Sleeping
Beauty before but Cinderella is often
the biggest offender to the sit back do
nothing to let someone else save the day
routine again toward offense she's
working her ass off I mean like every
second she's on screen she's doing
something and in the end she's rewarded
for her hard work and kindness even in
the face of such nastiness and if you
argument is this is still not a good
role model that it won't inspire people
to go out there and achieve guess whose
favorite fairy tale this was yep the D
man himself who supposedly started this
whole controversy Disney he said
Cinderella was his favorite because he
often felt like her working as hard as
he could every day until destiny finally
gave him a chance and that hard-working
kindness can result in the virtuous
reward but what does that arguably
greatest businessman creative genius and
heartwarming icon know slacker now
granted while I don't think these
characters are that bad it's clear to
acknowledge that these women were
limited to the roles that women were
expected to have at the time in the
following years the princesses would be
a little bit more proactive taking more
chances and forming more definitive
personalities but even that can get some
flag too particularly Ariel The Little
Mermaid who many complained is just a
whiny teenager who needs a man to save
the day and while she can at times
certainly be her own teenage drama queen
people forget at the time she was
praised as being much more independent
than the past Disney Princesses she
travels she explored she broke the rule
she left the house she had a distinct
personality she was curious the
character is active she's not just a
little girl that things happen to she's
up there she's going to go to the
surface she's gonna find her prince
she's going to take care of business and
so you can really identify that all and
on top of that while the prince does
save the day in the end she saves his
life
not once but twice in this movie hell if
we wanna get technical about it I'm
surprised more people weren't pissed off
at Jazmin I mean yeah she fights for her
independence once and even takes a
chance in living her own life but she
quickly returns to the world she said
she hated stays in it and constantly
lets her boyfriend save her but
nevertheless the complaints were heard
and the princess brand over the years
has made an effort to try and make their
ladies more and more independent having
them saved the male just as many times
as the male saves them while still
keeping true to the kind and moral
virtues that let's face it people are
enforced in every Disney character not
just the princesses be nice be kind be
true to your heart when has that not
been a major part of the lesson in a
Disney film so after looking all over
I'm not sure if it's entirely Disney's
fall for the negative stereotype okay
didn't always help but in many respects
it did help they're still trying to
teach the importance of patience and
kindness which are great virtues for any
gender and Disney is even pushing harder
to make their most marketable icons be a
symbol of strength and honor that's seen
in these recent ads I am a princess I am
brave even when I am scared
I believe compassion makes me strong
kindness is power so with the virtues
that the massive Disney's promoting
isn't the problem with the princess icon
what is I'll admit that something was
rubbing me the wrong way for years about
girls wanting to be princesses I just
couldn't put my finger on it but then
the answer came to me when I saw Bridge
to Terabithia which is a god-awful flick
by the way fact note to self review
bridge to terabithia
when our main lead brings his little
sister into his fantasy land
are you the changes and leave your
princess wait a minute
why is he King and her princess
shouldn't it more logically be king and
queen in fact even more recently in
wreck-it Ralph why is it when the king
is destroyed again it's a princess who
rules the land and not a queen in fact
how come in a lot of nostalgic shows and
movies ever viewed even if the original
ruler is gone they still hold the title
princess
yeah princess Sally princess Lada health
even princess lay up all their parents
are out of commission and yet they still
hold on to the title of Princess and not
Queen why does that seem more marketable
for some reason and that's when it
suddenly hit me it's not necessarily the
virtues of the princess that pissed
people off
maybe it's the title why did so many
boys want to be king because they want
the power and responsibility to control
and change things hail to the king baby
well then why do so many girls not want
to be queen them in fact we're almost
anti queen aren't we the more research I
did the more I found there aren't that
many fictional Queens that are kind
heroic women they're usually the
villains which brings us back to the
question why do so many girls prefer
princess to Queen well maybe because
being a princess not only indicates
you're younger which often translates to
prettier but also that you have a
position of power with responsibilities
but not too much responsibility oh I'm
just holding the spot for the king until
he returns I still have the title of
youthful innocent who has power but not
all the power that's projecting an image
of daintiness and elegance who makes
everybody cookies instead of an image of
strength and determination who makes
powerful changes it's the same thing as
calling a grown man a boy and a grown
woman a girl if you call a grown man a
boy they'll usually be pissed off why
because they want to be seen for
strength and responsibility over
youthfulness and innocence
whereas sadly many women do prefer the
other way around
valuing the youthfulness and innocence
over strength and responsibility well
don't get me wrong there's many who
don't but you all know
there there's plenty that do now why
this is is a whole other argument is it
society over nature and H over Society a
combination of both it's a whole other
issue and I'm also not forgetting that
Prince and princesses are not made up
titles they really exist it's not titles
we created to keep people in certain
roles their actual royal positions but
what is obvious is that our
reinforcement seems to be that
princesses are young beautiful and try
to live in an innocent world free from
conflict and if one does arrive it's
somebody else's job to take care of it
with that said no matter how tough
action-packed are honourable you make
your hero in' by keeping the princess
title a very popular title it's still
reinforcing that youth and the need not
to take all responsibility are the best
virtues and don't get me wrong I know
men and women are different
I know instinctually we're gonna have a
different emphasis on different values
men are from mars women from Venus etc
etc but the world is changing more and
more everyday and we're seeing much more
variety in our female characters than we
have in the past so maybe it's time to
really look at the changes happening
around us and see which virtues we
really want to enforce and at least
making it very clear that there's a
definite option that any female can be
as powerful as she wants to be and that
second place or being under somebody
else's wing is not the furthest you can
go because let's face it guys with so
many female characters that are good
strong interesting funny entertaining
intelligent responsible and just as
compelling as male characters perhaps
it's time for the princess and so many
people to stop living in fairy tales and
look at the reality that is unfolding
around us not lend a Schnauzer credit
guy remember so you don't have to
you
all right folks Premium Membership is
back but for the very last time in the
Unlimited for pay $40 and get access to
behind-the-scenes commentaries extras
and your favorite dog related videos all
downloadable in iPod format a once and
get it for as long as we're still a site
which hopefully will be a long time you
never know that sea horses might take
over but regardless future memberships
will be limited to a yearly basis also
get access to the downloadable back out
of the classes CD exclusives from the
vet guy of the glasses vol 1 2 and soon
coming 3 as well as kickassia suburban
nights coming soon as well click the
link below the video to purchase today
as new premium access will be closed on
April 20th 2013 hurry now because your
mother wants you to that's right I
called up and talk to your mother she's
totally on board with this go ahead do
it
alright maybe not your mother but my
mother is totally cool with it and sure
I haven't talked to my mother in a while
actually really I'll call my mother
hey mom how you doing yeah Kito these
people sign for the Premium Membership
okay thanks she says go for it my mother
says go for it dude that's my mom don't
let my mom down
you